little special surprise at the very end
another Star Wars gamecube game that
many people probably aren't aware of
because Oh Rob didn't streaming YouTube
are we gonna go to YouTube right now
goodbye
hello friends oh sorry for the delay
everyone happy may the fourth yeah here
we are now live on YouTube we're now
live on YouTube we're not live on
YouTube but now we are so who's watching
on twitch and GameSpot's gonna get a
second intro yeah hey what's up potato
top Peter and this is Rob and we're
playing rogue squadron and we had some
technical difficulties but now we're
good so we won't bore you with the
details
we're gonna be playing rogue squadron on
Nintendo 64 rogue squadron 2 rogue
leader on gamecube rogue squadron 3
rebel strike and then a special little
GameCube Star Wars game that many people
probably aren't aware of because it was
a bonus for people who pre-ordered rebel
strike right so don't hate but I never
had a Gamecube so I didn't play any of
those Rogue Squadron games they're so
good they were gonna hear because I was
a fanatic with squadron 464 and a lot of
suits for games for that matter but it's
aged yeah this has definitely aged but
we are playing if you want to speak more
on what we're actually like playing it
on sure so we are playing this on a
actual Nintendo 64 it's been kitted out
with the ultra HDMI internal mod so
it'll spit out it'll go beyond the
standard 240p you 480i and we can get
720p or 1080p out of this as you can see
that will definitely highlight that
intent of 64 is somewhat rudimentary
graphics we could add scan lines on top
of it but I think this looks pretty good
as is and the Gamecube is well we'll be
running over HDMI once we'd read over to
that we got a little external adapter
for that guy which works pretty well
oh man how does it feel having that
controller in your hands I was just
thinking it feels really weird I read
your mind buddy um but it looks really
it looks great I mean so we were
debating on what we were gonna play
today you know in honor of against Star
Wars day for those of you for those
people who know that like podracer came
out on GOG it upset Rob quite a bit did
not I mean it's just you stormed out of
work I was just like we're not gonna
play this because there was I mean just
I don't know it's it's a it's an old
game on a new operating system on PC
that maybe could be more flexible right
and the in flexibilities may get a
little bit tough to play right the new
version of gog I don't know it was just
freshening
frustrating experience I think this is
the way to do it like sorts really like
holding up on like just originality
right like the delivery and like what it
looks like the you know it looks really
good here compared to like a 4k screen
or for me at least just like even a cat
1080 like stretched 4:3 and like being
unable to like immediately turn it to
4:3 was like frustrating I don't know I
don't I just you know it just feels way
better of course for the controller I
didn't have I couldn't find out how do
you do controller support now the other
thing I every time likes we've been
testing the equipment a lot today every
time I pick up in tennis 64 controller a
system that I have like fond memories of
but I I don't really like to play that
much anymore anyway I keep grabbing the
outside handles it's like no dumbass
right I understand how to use the
controller but years have trained me not
to reach for the middle
yeah it was a nice reminder of how far
we when it comes to ergonomics there's
actually a new controller that came out
this year I was Kickstarter campaign for
about a year ago it's called the super
brawler controller or something like
that it actually puts the Nintendo 64
controls into a normal controller like
configuration so you don't have to have
a three-prong controller oh right I want
to see what you guys are doing on chat
if I can find it see here you'd think
the TIE fighter noise would get really
annoying with something knowing you love
it how excited are you for the solo
movie and be honest please I am I am
lukewarm Luke asked your father to get a
translator that speaks bocce I don't
think we have a choice I could do that
all day back to what Oh
pull up back to your question I don't
know it you know like the whole
production of that movie and development
has been like it's been interesting so
we'll see if mr. Ron Howard can pull
that off but it's just also a movie I
mean I I wasn't that jazz for rogue one
and that ended being really pretty solid
I think in retrospect I like that better
than
last year rub lon yeah I bet I've been
watching them both on repeat oh you know
I've had a lot of repeat viewings let's
say and yeah there's something about the
last Jedi I don't know if it's I think
it's just the impact is gone and it
feels very similar to what I come to
expect from Star Wars or rogue one just
it always just feels different enough
yeah
but it's also pretty simple and
straightforward it is and I think that's
it upholds the nostalgia right like it's
like the space battles in the end like I
think they're orchestrated like so much
like the originals yeah I mean obviously
they they have this exact same ship
designs and everything like that and you
know Admiral or Radice not acabar but I
think there are individual scenes in the
last Jedi that I prefer that I like more
than oh right rogue one that's how I
felt about last Jedi was was when I was
watching you when it came to blu-ray
what-have-you I found myself wanting to
skip to those moments there like the the
hall Doh hyper space jump like the
obviously the Praetorian Guard fight
it's just like I just want to get there
you know what I mean and like it's kind
of a grind it felt more so than I would
say force awakens force awakens I could
actually sit all the way through no
problem yeah yeah but I don't know I
it's but yeah
that being said solo I'm very I'm trying
to go in
[Music]
with expectations not high Mike you
might say low expectations yeah I mean I
did but then I don't know I think he's
all I forget his name the guy he's got
such a interesting last name isn't Alden
the guy playing han Solo
people were like really skeptical on him
and like trailers but okay I saw like us
an actual like I want to say 45 second
clip of like a asteroid chase scene yeah
did they put out today he sounded so
much like Han Solo it was like oh damn
like you know that being said with like
trailers you only getting snippets sure
he felt he felt pretty damn good and of
course I was telling you they had speak
of del they had like a Millennium Falcon
asteroid chase music like the they like
they're using all the the stuff you
would want out of out of like the Falcon
chase vampire like it was great they
know how to give you some nostalgia yeah
Luke's the bum happy right oh my god
that's right did you remember that the
ground the infantry troops they're like
I can't wait for you to play the game
keep games there's such a step up I mean
that's kind of why we obviously we're
starting with this is the first one
these guys I had to but they yeah man
factor 5 did amazing work with these
games on either platform honestly but
the GameCube games just really shine
well we're gonna jump every ever half
our power so we were a little late so
we'll take that into account or we could
do this maybe we could cut it short on
this one a little bit I think we got a
we got to do a next wing thing in this
one I think although honestly like oh
yeah let's bounce out of this it's good
yeah
let's try one more level here just to
give people a taste because I think the
x-wing is sort of like you know
obviously the most iconic ship but
especially in the Rogue Squadron games
although they're known for having just a
vast array of ships that you can use and
there's like you can put in codes to
unlock other ones right in this one yeah
I think it they had the Naboo Fighter
something like that in here before the
movie was even it like announced that's
the craziest thing and damn horik said
he was was working there oh right Lucas
and Lucas are and he remembered putting
that in which is something you don't see
anymore right
a secret like that being held on for
over a year I don't know man think about
all the Bethesda games that were
announced at least like a few months
later that's true but I guess I want to
say in game right like something that
it's in a game that's already existing
that hasn't been mine yeah yes in that
sense I would say yes this was always
funny to how you like it where's the
money I'm talking it's there but like
that was a code to get that you know you
want to fly this
we go but the imperial governor is
looting the city rogue quadrant you must
protect quick maybe he'll used to be
obsessed with wily obsessed with almost
it's always been the next wing for me I
never have any affinity for the other
ships next wing is pretty sweet don't
know why did I think it's just it's got
just this idea it just embodies like
utility flexibility speed aesthetics got
it all I do like how you change the fire
rate right yeah with l l our shoulder or
alt no L shorter that's what was was it
well so I think if you pressed down so I
just did it but down the C button it'll
also let you change oh no you're right
yeah the down C button will change
whether you fire independently or
together or all four yeah am i right
I literally like looked up the PDF oh I
know that noise I killed two people
mm-hmm
[Music]
Wow boots me all the way back out here
that's kind of aggressive I'm gonna get
a little weird and nerdy here for a
minute so one of the things with the
Nintendo 64 mod that I've got in my
system is it incorporates sort of
intelligent firmware that reverses via
math this sort of like inherent blur
that most of 64 games have so if you
notice that the pixels here are pretty
crisp it's because it's not just because
we're using a high quality signal it's
because we've also gone a step further
to reduce that blurred intensity for
like literally adds to the video before
it spits it out which is also very
interesting we are playing this leave
without the jumper pack in the jumper
pack would turn this game into 480i
versus 240p which is somewhat ironic
because that's considered like the
high-res mode really it's just a slower
interlaced version of what you were
getting before it allows for higher res
textures but yeah so I kind of prefer it
for this game to play in the classic
version without the check
well we don't have any Rogue Squadron
games and I heard you guys talking
earlier about the stuff in Battlefront I
don't know I was hoping I could like
play these games beforehand oh yeah I'm
blaming blame and blame it blame it on
it oh cool oh man we were being exposed
let's hop into some GameCube video games
how about how about that Rob entertain
the people sorry about sorry about all
that it's been a while I should be
really good at that game
happy happy fourth everyone what are you
excited for about Han Solo movie put
them in the comments we'll read them
Chewbacca
mmm what am i excited for how's that
going oh dude I wonder what the
detaching part of the Millennium Falcon
is gonna be you know I mean people are
saying like is it like an escape pod you
know like that how it fills in right
thanks for chiming in I'm expecting it
to be like Lando's sweet little bachelor
pad like exclusive VIP champ VIP
champagne yeah I was a VIP champagne
room you know I mean I know exactly what
you mean up next we're playing which--it
we're gone rogue one rogue squadron two
rogue leader fantastic
we're swap we're swapping from 64 to
Gamecube
should I be expecting feed or looking at
feed here okay here we go
this controller won't work you fly ah
I'm back I am back yes
damn really yes that's a pretty amazing
intro so for the third game it's even
better we'll see that later
and now hell yeah presenting
[Music]
factor 5 buckle up hell yeah
whoa smv do it swap
[Music]
[Music]
Nana well done before never is the first
time for everything
there you go oh man it is so much nicer
over here breeze at my back what kind of
name we want you got three letters use
them wisely
ABC oh dude always be Chewbacca
Chewbacca okay sure baka say he was
nineteen hundred years old oh good
Oh sick people are actually in the room
now debris from the circus and the TIE
fighter is defending the approach to the
trash they got the same vo and 3d
holograms in 3d so this is this is -
that's my Don Pardo and which one this
is real squadron that was awesome rogue
leader rogue leader featuring x-wing
I'm into it Luke's the bomb says this is
the best looking game tape games it's
true though I will say I will say the
third one that does it but it's still
pretty good
David McGuire says how old did they say
true Baca was in the trailer
ah that's the question he's like a
hundred and want to say they're like a
hundred and fifty you somebody that get
out here yeah you remember you didn't
see that part of the trailer no I'm
aware of it I was exaggerating so it's
gonna make us sit through this so let's
sit through it a second skip it I can't
[Music]
but 240 years 130 wait there's
difference here in comments
it's difference of 90 110 years
[Music]
all right so this is this is in between
a new hope and it's basically a note a
new hope yeah okay why do they have to
set this up them because it's a side
story who do you fly as Luke yeah I
believe you can play as wedge and some
of the other games apparently we should
look at Bear Warfare's vids for what I
wonder what he has going on bunch of
bunch of bears just a bear combat guides
for bears to fight so you're a bear and
you're looking to fight step one
you've come to the right place step one
lose those hands and get robot human
hands to use all their weapons oh cool
so this is the special effects of
treatment that gigas brought with the
remasters it's about no one knows what
beer I'm drinking you can't see anything
it is you just put them you just put
Kabuto 190 is Chewbacca's age to the
trailer I'm going after the towers
alright alright alright so if that's the
case then in like the new trilogy he's
what
two hundred thirty forty years old baby
I don't know and you don't want to know
this looks a lot better
oh man you got
wingman and everything blah
liking to meet the score here
we first-person action
yeah I'm I'm actually very surprised you
totally played these before I'm not
saying that as like shouldn't you play
these but like I feel like somewhere
along the line you would have seen this
and be like what the hell cuz I think
this is
you can see like the heat vortex of your
proton torpedo well infrared action and
your JIT give it to it down I'm running
out of time
can't talk goddamn it where's my fast go
fast button
Luke thanks it's red five I'm not
hitting any buttons it's just skipping
oh yeah I don't think you did it
really
wait a minute didn't I destroy that
thing when it said one more maybe you
got punished for skipping that cutscene
row it's murky beam says you're not
using the force [ __ ] oh wow alright I'm
not gonna screw around here no oh there
are my towers okay but where are the
towers [ __ ] my shot
using the holes Louise that looks off I
like I like the idea of just like insane
particles it's like it seems like a
different Oh close may the force restart
the level
christop says you have no more torpedoes
look at ya one more oh that's what he
said oh you have to keep your tone Gatos
you gotta save one for the ending finale
man oh that's right that's funny I'm a
bad bad boy okay busted Luke's the bomb
says I play better than you guys because
I'm Luke and I have all right all right
now we get it like the debris is falling
so quickly to the surface I mean I guess
there's insinuating that Death Star's
got hella gravity this looks off to me
it's kind of insane Spencer yeah I don't
know all right so using Jersey on your
torpedoes man
easy on the Pepsi fourth you got to have
that one-in-a-million shot dude Joey
says remember the movie oh you got free
roll there I do a barrel roll
it's red five
yes one comes after two don't skip it
the signal is 640 by 304 okay now at 640
by 450
christop it's some hot tips which are
Chris top tips if you don't click down
on the right trigger all the way but
slightly you will go faster without
closing the wings mark marked her turd
turgon wants to see a flip dude turgon
smarter there's no time samargan my
Jurgens
also I agree use the radar well the
thing is I have to hold the button down
okay up around my room I write on Oh the
radar gotcha
use the false move but also this helps
tell you
yeah get her man
I'd like to take a little damage I'd
like to feel like I'm I'm threatened
whoa just a little bit Wow
at some point you'll just be like yeah
that's good enough
dude Flint I can't do a flip right now
all right is the chat to riding me I
wouldn't blame them no they're saying
you're doing yeah damn blonde thanks
chat record just be saying that I could
be but I
I guess I would lie to you which is why
I doubted you but always something truth
I'm a jerk you know even if you were
jerk I still wouldn't lie to you because
I'm a good guy thank you nice shot who
is this guy how many FPS this feels like
60 to me two more to go well where are
they
Luc's the bomb bring in all the energy I
love it he says this case it looks good
looks good
makes me feel better about being alive
yeah I would definitely play this I'm
gonna lie ROK's water and I can get back
into the original took support it's just
like it's just hell yeah that's closed
up you guys what was weird in in the 64
version of the trench run in the 64th
version of trench run it was like it was
almost a triple the size like you could
you could do 360s in the trench it
wasn't an arrow like a obviously rep the
narrowness like that was represented in
the movie in here as well it was weird
and I think was a bonus level in six
support oh damn
we got a lot of I feel like and you're
going real fast yeah buddy I'm living
now this is podracing that yippee
okay we got a lot of role-playing here
in the chat Lord
Oh excess Vader's gonna kill you really
fast do me slow Vader wait what yeah
what I remember there being so many
ridges in the trench okay
can't make that gameplay fun right I'm
living dangerously you think in a video
game I just fly right but like
absolutely nothing you dope down into it
well I was going too fast a fire because
I wasn't following the advice of our
friend got another crisp top tip when
the ties show up break real hard
remember that remember
ooh cotton to five says looks better
than battlefront to EA damn
no pair of cats still add up that quote
should I use the high ground
oh hey it's fader use the forest Vader
you didn't stay low
I was already high by the time he told
me it's all right
this is video game
you think they cut out Luke's like
animation when he responds like he's
like it hurts every time I don't have an
index finger anymore I can't do this I
can't do this a tenth time well mark
says if if you died he's leaving to him
no thanks dad can't wait for your movie
oh that would be cool this I mean
anything that comes out in tennis which
would be amazing this gosh
factor of five is a real small company
now though they don't really exist the
way they used to
unfortunately
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't show that you did it oh look at
all of those awesome stats I did a
acceptable job we got a cheeseburger
french fries soda ice no man in red cup
I don't know what it means love it
goodness do you want to play this one
I'm sorry
no don't worry you say that every time I
think he liked it no you do say that
every time he rolls his eyes cuz he
knows he loves it damn wish I could fly
that F&B wing for but friggin B wing why
didn't they call it T wing am i right do
you know do you know why they called it
B wing why no I'm asking you
legitimately I don't have any jokes I
think when it's collapse baby first
person this is wild one of the
rebellions most well-armed starfighters
the B wing has been personally designed
by Admiral Ackbar
the big wing supports an array of
weapons including ion cannons proton
torpedo launchers and laser cannons
because the cockpit is surrounded by a
unique gyro stabilization system the
pilot always remained stationary even as
the rest of the ship rotates during
flight
Wow I could listen to that all day there
it is
why are there two x-wings does one have
recliner check it out well so I can't
find a b-wing yeah no not on this
mission you know I bet though no I mean
like it said you could write oh yeah
maybe there's a code
[Music]
got removed but you're ending your
ending when there was lucky as f luck
has nothing to do give me a rundown on
controls okay so to fire is the a button
accelerate is this one and because it's
analog yeah don't click it all the way
down if you don't want to collapse this
brings up your thermal this does
first-person innovation or third and
this will gosh this game looks freaking
beautiful accelerate yeah no what is it
No oh sorry no it was this one so saying
oh it is yeah yeah so be cool feel it
click if you go although s-foils is
click ooh that's good I like this man
this game looks so good I smell Tie
Fighters
oh I just realize the TIE fighter crew
down throw up no it's good
sorry it sounds like sounds like a
rattlesnake
oh hell yeah
yeah not realistic effects dude I don't
know I was just being fun were you
okay where are you
just makes me bummed out that there
wasn't a great starfox game on game 2
man I was playing some starfox 64
earlier today - yeah it's sort of you
know wash away the taste of the original
rogue squadron which is okay but it's
it's aged definitely aged I like old
games but that one's aged quite a bit
but does it look better with the
polygons it kind of owns it right
starfox yeah would you could you say
that I post them like well I would you
think of a what you think of an x-wing
you know what I mean like it certainly
captures the x-wing aesthetic more if
you will but I guess what I'm saying
like I don't know starfox just has
because it's so focused and linear
because it's on Rails they're able to do
much more with the environment it goes
as the original rogue squadron felt very
sparse and the stuff was all simple
because any moment you can eat Omega air
within that environment and that game
had to keep up look at all of this you
have commands right oh yeah yeah that's
pretty cool I don't know how to use them
effectively
it seems pretty general this guy
who's your a thermal thing
skip I catching a sin of omission fair
marnark sub x starfox assault was I
think they're good game I I don't know
I'm I'm such a stickler for starfox when
it comes to certain things so it just
wasn't what I was looking for let's put
it that way
it was certainly better than starfox
adventures I'm sorry to anyone who loved
that game but then I feel like having
starfox be the basis for that was not in
his favor
you guys are quick what just oppose that
cinematic I don't know hey watch it hey
I'm flying here sit down
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah you just I think there general just
go for ties or form up touch me and see
what the other one was hmm go home
save yourself
what do you prefer cockpit er there
I prefer third yeah I just feel like
more ego yeah exactly
soak up the ambiance hey I was just
thinking about this year we supposed to
get an ace combat ace combat is that
that's not confirmed yet is it no I'm
pretty sure it's this year I want to say
it maybe it's just generally 2018 but
I'm pretty sure it's this year I hope so
I hope so too you know what I want is a
new Ridge Racer not I'm new and I'm
talking about that is the same I want a
new bridge racer that's not like
gimmicky I just want like a classic
arcade switch to an a wing that's it
thank you mom yeah I don't know how you
would do that though I think you looking
a prom and during the nebula keep your
eyes peeled
Oh barrels but you got it you have to
waiting if I'm gonna keep it up that's
the thing
which I get otherwise the game might
feel it balance
interceptors now huh
please get me out of here stop dumb
voiceover it's stupid
no I do I will see Luke Skywalker we
need your help that's fine
there you go whoa okay
this switch this thing is you wanting
first person you know what's this oh
that's how you switch oh cool let's
check out that anyway it's got a little
more maneuverability
Oh
awaiting your orders okay free
awaiting your orders look get out of
your guys leave me alone oh you can't
bring him back great but take you
seriously like whoo I am done with this
war
Oh my radars in the bottom-left that's
kind of hard to see
it's realistic dude
good job red squadron see inhale nebula
nice work
laya appreciates it oh yeah what are you
doing you almost got a medal all right
well it's our clinical bill thanks for
joining the street got here you go play
a little more of this one I think so
okay cool I'm in you want to play sure
why the hell not oh man monarchs
upcoming with all the great info all you
guys are gray in the chat and it's
preparing an invasion oh hi
how was the tow cable in this every game
has a different way of doing it I feel
like and they're all really crappy which
one do I want
come on speeder which one says Luke
this one says right here yeah I get top
throws at helmet C's helmet down
yeah it's pretty cool consider wearing
long underwear bundling pretty nippy
I don't want any of my pilots catching a
cold
let's go oh sure we'll shooting what are
you shooting so many bullets
let's get wet
yikes
[Music]
jerk
I got a dare for you I got a dare for
you flying between the legs
oh that direction you dog it's cool
they're probably my turrets
Chris top tip go for the 80s C's first
yeah how do I get my Tokyo bladder maybe
that's like a Phase two
oh boy
oh hey sub T what's up T twitch chat
we're getting unloaded on oh there we go
Oh all right use press the B button use
your alternate fire button close
go down
no I think you
I think you blew it tried again oh
thanks Rob
was a release has followed the objective
indicator I think
yeah go for those ad SDS all right fair
enough we lost the war
thanks guys I gotta get out of here I'm
going to dig about sorry we are not that
good
oh is this a bazooka tip use your
targeting computer primary objectives
are gold colored
I like that guy guys what's up I mean if
my main objections gold they're my gold
guys david says you can't even hurt 8080
with guns sick that armors too thick why
the hell does that keep happening just
slow down when you do that
Oh golly
no people david McGuire wants to know
what Star Wars gave me this this is
rogue leader - rogue squadron - rogue
leader okay or rogue leader wrote
spotters you want right okay damn
this was really hard and it's not that
it's not that hard I feel like I'm just
I'm missing it by
Josh Keller I don't know if you do know
and you're just joking around but no
this is not Battlefront 2 DLC this is
okay you're joking
please
well bless you sorry I blocked out Oh
so you're gonna want to use the little
red B button to launch recheck people
those guys look pretty big and
comparison with my [ __ ] that's true
leave them alone oh here we go
oh you can't really crash right because
it's a speeder doesn't it like bounce
off I don't know why don't you find out
oh okay you got it
what's up multiple no it's loop stuff
hell yeah Campbell Astor's blast him
use your harpoons and tow cables go for
the legs it might be our only chance of
stopping them that's why we have these
things a guy with binoculars legit
he's holding his ground
it's cinematic very long
activate Hakone oh so you don't even do
it
I feel like this a stability this is
showing you what to do I mean what do
you you'd have to swap two different
four different
Oh
you switched with your pilot then
requisite cousin fire boys you swapped a
wedge NAR she blows
child it hello Moomin thank you for
joining us Oh this goes way better
oh it's got way better speaker all right
what's the tow cable it's a little red B
button we do fall down we just try
trying coming in at speed run Oh God
yeah what stop you in huh you don't want
to do this okay I'll swap you out right
after this mission won't you come on
Mike before although Mike Hardy's orders
hi hello
don't shout into the Michaels
this is Kaldor
yeah roach water to Rohleder I know we
are on Hoth Rob is saving low Jesus gosh
all right Mike I'll swap you in right
now I'll tell you I'll tell you what
hey my only concern is swapping games oh
that's no problem you just you hit the
open button and then you put in the
other disk close it all right I don't
have a Gamecube never had one no you set
that along five folks hey how are ya
good good good good good good good I'm
just I'm just knocking these walkers
down left right how many maybe you guys
talk about us I wasn't watching how many
times you think you played through HOF
in a video game
yeah right it's a staple of that one I
guess he's got a warm button well this
book room gets warm I mean there's
galactic battlegrounds which I played
Empire at war or you want to go through
mall shadow that was the Empire higher
you go through and on Empire Strikes
Back nest game right
rogue squadron about it not just kidding
there's a lot more battlefront 1 & 2 & 1
& 2
yeah was it in battlefront - again last
year two years ago no Ehrmann
I don't think it was I don't blame him
the way it's like to pull off from a
gameplay perspective right like what
perspective do you go with choice
challenging my opinion but did you play
the Clone Wars back game there's all
mostly vehicle based on it was like
early Xbox GameCube era
sorry not early was later on it was
essentially a rogue squadron game like
vehicle based it was actually kind of
fun but that's where they got those Jedi
tanks from you know those look like yeah
that's where I don't know if that's
where they came from but you use those a
lot you're mainly anakin and obi-wan
looks cool
it's no speeders a joke - yeah
and this at the time was pretty yeah new
x-wing being in unhaul right in
atmosphere the first time we saw them in
atmosphere was in fourth awakens maybe
not in a mature but like fighting in
atmosphere
as far as the movies go yeah right yeah
I mean a bunch of x-wings escorting the
the truth transports out during the
movie I mean as far as combat goes yeah
no they didn't they were shooting the
cannons nevermind I don't know [ __ ]
yeah Clone Wars you got an eighty PT
take a tte mm home big elephant thing
but what was the name of the tank that
the Trade Federation use I forgot what
they had a couple weird things first
Clone Wars they had those like I don't
know I described other than like giant
wheels yeah those are like kind of
mobile [ __ ] my action figures I had
the slave one I had the Falcon I had and
my action figures and not like like not
including Lego or anything but I had and
then the cloned dropship the gunship
that's my favorite those ladies yes yes
LA 80s yeah those are my favorite
vehicles were pretty sweet yeah the ATT
yeah that's what was so interesting I
felt like about those movies was like
that was like one thing I like always
saw or enjoyed and will continue to joy
out of those movies yeah you know
despite the acting being pretty much
abysmal to place Starfighter when you
start off in the
what's the name of the big yellow they
just call like the Naboo Starfighter oh
yeah yeah I like those ships I like all
the designs for the nations are pretty
sweet
that was its own whole yeah I collected
battlegrounds Naboo had its own faction
blaka powders
great job broker follow those transport
get on it are you an ad a person or
agency it's both I've gone in arguments
before with people
[Music]
would link to like toy ads that would
they would say a dad but like it's
actually never really said in the movies
yeah it's just walkers imperial walkers
so I think that's like the argument that
Star Wars has said like it's both
he's let's join forces everyone well the
arguments always like well you don't you
don't say they're a tsts that's my
argument but I always called the
installation has been detected in the
heart of the mall a dangerous region as
we have twitter game escape the imperial
installation we want to swat as much
damage as Penn Lau played to others
there's only three ropes but I want to
swap cuz I'm afraid I'm just gonna like
make that game keep explode here
and tight
[Music]
I uh I wouldn't know I've never played
these to be honest I would know it's
next what's after this so rebel strike
the game is still on
something like you gotta restart
which is white they're gray
I don't all right
noobs did you put the cheat code in
unlock the car wasn't that just in the
64 version the car do you want playing
progressive mode no clue yeah yeah it
sounds good
this is rebel strike yes
we're rockin baby who's Pete who's who
Peter Brown Denton Dhin Dhin Dhin Dhin
Dhin Denton did first time I ever played
a game feed without a McDonald's
[Music]
you know you never see this this is
right up your alley just go and start
work this is so dumb this is how that
Han Solo
[Music]
well I could watch that another 20 times
just hold my cup dad be slightly out of
control awesome wonder if this is one of
Pete's old saves go with bark you can't
do that can you 93 back
bag Wow I need to watch that another
five more times right this is an
allagash white solid burgers homework do
you have to do the training womp rats
back home been Janka saves huh huh what
about Janka I don't know do we have
saves on this oh this is I don't know
oh shoot everyone accent what following
the orange wedge oh [ __ ] whoa this guy
everybody weirdest dodge good job try it
now
yeah what are you doing pressing the r
button you can reach your next mission
objective I'm just rolling I don't think
I have a choice I'm doing I just I don't
think I have a choice I'm doing edge on
the radar screen
press the X button to join there we go
try it now
good job pressing start shows you're
crying now
good job that dam broke squadron's hey
uh why is he ready have you can reach
your next mission objective oh this is a
very important training to do for a
broke spouses thing I was just there you
can duck by pressing the arm button
right there the scenic icon appears when
you can perform a special action push
the c-stick in any direction to open the
door good job one of the blue symbols to
select a craft yeah I agree I don't I
don't think I don't think this is
mandatory people are saying oh really
huh well whoa
how do I skip it I might even have that
gun on it I think it's gigantic I do
want to see some of this [ __ ] what's
that what's that thing called the
Warhawk 8:10 yeah yeah it's just like
sound like a fart man yeah you should
play corn were at some point well or
check it out don't play it you probably
got better things to do
no I'm so seasick I'm assuming it's the
yard or the pitch or is there go go left
yeah you could probably skip this this
is just gonna be boring story yeah I
think you can and training and training
I hope this isn't there might be another
save on this this is about let's bounce
all these
then yeah I'm bored too Michael Robinson
Michael Robinson my man you're boring
not just kidding
okay cool Michigan mission select will
go with Ben Django saves everyone okay
okay so this is uh this is probably post
a new hope correct they know where you
are still they're coming after ya they
know you're there they told me they told
me uh see stickers action but I guess
not my name is Luke let's get me out
here I'm going to war
uh-oh oh no this title scroll says can
we skip this
probably no own it
ROK's quadrant three
[Music]
rebels with all the text all the scroll
is narrated by the Emperor it died it
isn't the back I'm not doing all thing
okay okay you know crushing the Alliance
[Music]
yeah so this is before Empire right yeah
I mean if they're saying they're saying
that you're defending Gavin I bet that's
like exactly right after all before the
Glee - ha that'll be a vignette wedge
I'm gonna use my favorite character
growing up yeah always
nice shot right -
half an hour later alright now we're
getting a good stuff here we go alright
meanwhile on yevon what's the best
opening tour star wars maybe we'll check
everyone I really like force awakens
when the yeah I would the negative
comments comes in to the yeah I agree
with you it's so tight
was that a moon of jakku or was that
jaku that they actually wanted to it's
like a moving up jacket and then it
pants down cuz the New Hope's just to
start destroyed in the Karelian forget
what's empire oh it goes down to look at
Hoth right nothing really it's a Star
Destroyer no cereal for yeah the probes
return the Jedi was tattooing because
his job was what was anything happening
in space or now I think it's just boring
tactic or just paying down to Jabba's
palace I can't return to Jedi no I think
about it
yeah it was a fun mapping on battlefront
the first to mine these hard cuts to
black er dramatic
they were ahead of their time back then
I was just talking to the day Joey here
at Gamestop plays most games I inverted
job quite a weirdo yeah but with games
like this on my left hand I need
inverted the n64 like Goldeneye days and
that's how choice ik works
that battle yeah this is a lot of Thai
fighters what am I doing this my wedge
or lucre now sounds like it's supposed
to be move right
Oh
is that these things back here
B is proton gotcha
whoop
whoa
got them
oh did I use all my throat I have to
pick up more they recharge I think again
sent them out
whoops probably could use like one on
there keep it up
nope what's my temple
stop what you're hitting it again this
one time what you're hitting the tempo
don't shoot my eyeball good air peaceful
people that thing is gigantic swing
yeah
yeah Battlefront serious dough
I owe you one charlie they're calling
him commander and it's in a span of like
two hours Luke went from just like a
pilot to a commander destroyed the
deaths are in his defense and that's
just immediate promotion from from
[ __ ] farm boy to farm boys a
commander of likes
yeah pretty good he sounds like such a
dork it's the bomb sounds I got
okay here we go more transports I'm
taking say yeah
they're technically sift temples Wow
very my back I didn't know that so I'll
[ __ ] him up
where'd that other transports go I'm
sorry
well Wow
those unfolding walkers
Walker's out on an island mm she's a bad
drop-off
all right died you look like you're
about to nice he is that's kind of funny
yeah how long after a new hope that
Empire takes take place oh why weeks or
something a lot early years I don't
think I'll return the Jedi Empire was
definitely years I don't even think the
monks but I don't even think Luke was a
commander in Empire no one ever called
him completely called him commander and
returns jeddah I don't know him calling
and we know he Mandarin Empire turns
Jedi's women but they would pay sir yeah
no I don't work at I but you're right I
think you're right I'm sure I think of
at the beginning when he's lost and I
was looking for a man they say commander
just Luke Skywalker it's possible I feel
I feel like this game would have made
sure to stay canonically correct
right I mean it seems like a pretty
obvious thing but guess always have to
watch them all this weekend I still
watched last Jedi more than once
it looks like the generals retreated oh
man they really went in as like shadows
the Empire now [ __ ] going
type
come on all right
Bang Bang Chitty Chitty Bang Bang where
are you
Fang Fang should shoot him bang bang I
love you
was that Chi Chi BAE bang is that wedge
with me yeah more like was you sick yes
there's a war precursor just Luke firing
slipping lasers and the guy's skulls I
love those glass displays camera great
look like you just like Fanning the
hammer on that gun what's your least
favorite Star Wars character those in
charge are my least favorite well I
actually like Jar Jar I think he's a
great addition to the Star Wars
franchise Ciotti money
don't
I gotta think I don't know you go if you
got one I'm gonna think about this is
like adolescent Anakin count Hayden
Christensen or is that does that
encompass like him as bait or - no
that's that's a pretty well don't I like
you know it was really I I don't know if
this would be it cuz I feel like if
there's probably a work one but um I
don't remember
Oh young Boba Fett is annoying yeah when
he's no you know Jango everything yeah I
don't really but the one character that
I can remember his name that obi-wan
talks to with where he gets the dart
from Django and goes to that one guy
who's like this fat diner owner oh yeah
[Music]
did you like Sebulba I like simple I
like simple like awesome design yeah
he's funny he's gross
he's just such a freaking [ __ ] this
honestly is not far off from how
firefights in Star Wars actually happen
Dexter jettster thank you he's the dude
diner it's a diner right what do you
know yeah it's diner Dex I'm [ __ ]
sick at this game Dex yeah Sam was L
I had an action figure her
I think there's someone I'm missing that
I really don't like member when Padme
fell on to the what were the name of
those three animals Padme was gonna get
that tiger thing and I came when up
against the RAM one was a reek the RAM
was the reek and then that tiger thing I
forgot what it was but then she falls
onto it after Anna contains it then
kisses him on the cheek quick and then
they start writing toward the other fan
a clay oh he wants fighting the acolyte
and I'm trying to member what the last
small one was start with a pea I think I
don't know you vote okay actually no I
think I know what it is because this
because this is like a personal
occurrence for me I think I've told the
story before but I remember being I
remember when episode one came out I was
into it because it was pretty freakin
cool when he looked at it from like a
special-effects standpoint racing was
like it was like this is smooth and I
was young enough to be like I love that
movie
really cool also it was the first time
you or I got to see a Star Wars in
theaters right I was released yeah and
then it was attack of the clones I
remember being theater and remember
hearing about how like people some
people didn't like the first episode 1
but remember attack the clones
who's ever being in theater when all
that love scene ol crap was happening
and it was the scene where Anakin and
Padme are riding giant ticks on Naboo
and they fall off and like this is some
random romantic [ __ ] but I remember
seeing that and thinking oh god this
movie sucks so I would say that giant
tick if that's a character that's it
that's it salacious crumb is a good one
that little stupid [ __ ] thing that
sits in Javas folds no you like that
yeah without bib Fortuna with the
butt-head in the snake ponytail he's
weird
I could see him being a creepy voice
actor who did that creature he came and
did like a like a senior year like
public speaking to our likes course I
don't know and he like did all he like
did all those characters you like did a
whole bunch room for Lucas oh wait so he
wasn't the only one he voiced
yeah he like did a whole range of
different characters inside yeah what's
happening I don't
we're on Dantooine I know that cool cool
uniforms different
what yo yeah oh look at this oh man
I'd love that noise the fire rate on all
these how about I go as fast as I can
for the whole time limited oh there's
rights there are probe droids in 10
dollah gee I
I agree does either you love that guy
you hate him that's fair I just yeah I
could I could easily see someone hate
him so you're gonna if you don't like
him that's a toy who's better he had
done do your duty Jar Jar no I'll do it
later
bad ads in here dad duck call ya who do
I really like I'm just a lot but I see I
was overheating I really I think I have
to say my favorite character just from
an enjoyable 'ti standpoint is wicked
come on really no not like you're not
characterization wise but like I
considered naming a pet wicket once or
twice I like the name you don't like
wicked I'm not I was never a huge fan of
Ewoks ever oh I was like that was a
fresh drink fire about that return Jedi
movie despite its still being my
favorite Star Wars movie
it still is yeah Rose yeah I eat I still
have to watch last Jedi again I like I
think I like rose more than Finn in last
Jedi
I like Finn though I like Finn I should
say at present tense
these are we missing dialogue because
I'm loving just these awkward
yeah we must be that's cool-looking [ __ ]
maybe not I don't know maybe they're
just wait I'd be bummed bull grenade
playing this game because there seems to
be a lot of boots on the ground man yeah
I'm [ __ ] killing it with it 2z roll
out
like Lube you don't need to be rolling
it's overkill
this is just a lot of tapping a am I
supposed to [ __ ] destroy this thing
yes
oh no no you don't know damn they kind
of take keep shooting me Wow whoa whoa
can I get on this can I get on this Oh
all right what's facing the other way
thank you advance down is this thing on
my side or no stop focusing on it no
apparently not I don't know why do they
keep doing that
maybe you know it is you're escorting it
but that's drawing my auto aim toward it
nice shot Luke no there's bechet's
coming out of it isn't it
I don't know man this is a great home
did I run out of lives or something yeah
no yeah you ran out wash hmm maybe I can
go to Ben janko's yeah let's see versus
whoops I did have to destroy it
oh go uh oh it's just oh did I write it
ah here we go
would be this one where are they at
that's bad well that's me that one this
is Edie yeah then again
mm-hmm yeah they've got no medals oh
that doesn't mean anything let's just
take a look at it that's still yevon
maybe there's level select I hope so
I doubt it oh here we go nice okay cool
okay go back okay we you're doing
training no I backed out okay good it's
just the long fade to black okay here we
go I'll destroy that transport the Sun
wait that's oh that's now these are new
oh I play it all right here you go
we had a debate this is a debate that
frequently comes up I sit next right
next to rob in the office and I don't
like being on a debate just an argument
Rob likes b-wings I think they're very
dumb ok viewings are cool as [ __ ]
I think they are I know Josh former
GameSpot producer also like some I don't
like them a wings are not aesthetically
pleasing but functionally I love them
you don't think a wings are
aesthetically pleasing I mean they're
born I mean X wings are dope as [ __ ] Y
wings like as a bomber whatever but no a
wings just imagine being in the cockpit
of one of those I would I would [ __ ]
swoop in swang left and right if you
know how to be dialog oh I didn't see it
but the Rebel Star Wars rebels did a bit
on the B wing and my like seemed almost
like they were pulling on the idea of
like the a wing it was right the a-10
warthog in real life how like apparently
the buing was created around a gun or
something like that
parents anthem is more about it or maybe
someone the comments could like
enlighten me but apparently fire from
all three spokes or just those two
oh Lisa Valley
yeah the Jedi star fighters are actually
pretty dope looking I like those a lot
those like I would like the Corvette of
star fighters they look like a Corvette
in space
my favorite spaceship though ship in
general I really really like the Clone
Army gunships
but again I also really like the Jedi
Starfighter
my host use my ion cannon these hold B
then release someone said yeah yeah shot
that into space wonder how long they
take to dissipate or if my mission here
I just try the fleeing okay so with okay
alright with the ion cannon okay
maybe that'll take out the shields and
he just laser it up you have my star
fighters in this game
wait that looks like a rebel transport
on top of Imperial one sake
Oh
we're gonna land the shuttle on my desk
maybe that's not work
hey I'm doing it
the slave one is pretty
general grievous was a dumb character I
didn't like him I mean he was cool when
I first saw him
oh it's already disabled all right thank
you very much thank you thank you thank
you I guess that makes sense
typical Star Wars fashion if it's like
covered in blue shields a guy who is
already disabled what plan are you over
right now
well yeah we do have some sort of audio
bush
because I think what should be talking
to us to this whole time might be just a
problem with our capture stuff in here
I lost a wingman
yeah
hear them behind me
I know there is
how many times you seen last Jedi oh
wait include him take that back
including in theaters that was five I
won't see it once
oh really mm-hmm watch rogue one three
times I like that a lot more now that I
saw it again this eye fighter behind me
it was excellent you can really shooting
a lot
actually I swear I gotta go
is behind you somewhere you shoot
well you have to reboot the cube
Nadia boy probably oh I thought that was
an objective in this game it's a Metal
Gear Solid [ __ ]
it's like a solar shield that thing is
on it has okay what movie was that
Revenge of the Sith
or no no oh no no no I think it's Attack
of the Clones or they're going to
Geonosis they like the jedi starfighter
flocked into that hyperspace thing
lights must be yeah yeah needed in order
there was an alien movie was a covenant
when they were repairing the Solar
shield I forgot what it was
oh wait you're thinking of a sunshine
that happens well but there's another
one where it's like you have to protect
the rebel tree yeah there's definitely
audio protect the rebel transfers thank
you
well I'm doing great I'm doing it these
guys
oh there's one it's probably Thai
fighters flown around or something oh
there we go
it's kind of boring it's up Junior
almost house
Jr whoa what's that I don't know oh [ __ ]
broadsiding
all right just shows up Oh nope it's
planning a getaway weird without the
dialogues definiteness of dialogue
but reset it after this mission maybe
call it wait wait swing reset it after
this mission well we could just swap to
the next game and then ya end on that
actually the other game is also a rebel
strike but it's like it says bonus
preview dis alright let's do it will it
be different yeah that's not like the
expansion I have no idea I think that's
what Peter was telling me wow okay I'll
do it
alright swap it Oh super stardestroyer
hell yeah oh hell yeah
put it in you dorks says Peter Brown
that's probably okay reset it bottom
left button Peter what is this it just
has preview disk what's what's Peter up
to this guy's always up to something
he's got those long cons left and right
ooh that's interesting
monarch says that mission had two
different ending weird audio there
should be seen gameplay yeah I said
reset it
I don't think were that good at it
monarchs KUB monarchs odd max oh hell
yeah
starwars arcade is that what he wants us
to play
which one is it Peter pick the thing in
the menu that looks different
no hell no JM I'm up I'm a full on open
that dis trade before I press power kind
of person oh here we go see what's oh
man oh God
tied damn this looks good this is the
expansion select a death star fire laser
at Oh gotcha don't easily Harvey easy
legit
Wow yeah that's a good expansion yeah it
is
it's time [ __ ] I'm good at this
you and I shoot fireballs [ __ ] shoot
fireballs oh they're called proton
torpedoes you idiot its Kenobi man the
trench run man you're kissing Reverse
what you're in Reverse damn oh it worked
how do you even file that I've barely
cooked
are you up for our hard - to see what
their auras are we already done yet oh
no no oh it's another death it's another
Death Star vector graphics are hard to
see in a stream
sorry
can't
is this on hard cancel out and do it
again hon what wait what's going on I
don't know I don't know how to cancel
that's all the buttons what is that is
that it that's on this disk I quit
okay I don't know how to can you reset
the game okay Jesus
anything else is just a demo just watch
I got some artwork all right oh it's a
movie yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Wow hey
[Music]
that
[Music]
what is that bocce
[Music]
your backstory is about to be brewing
soon not just kidding we'll see oh it's
good hopefully it's good go in with an
open mind
different yeah what's that
the try scepter what was the um oh that
thing's dope that's all cool what is the
three wings TIE fighter called not a
defender alright where we can um you
wanna call it yeah we can call it okay
supposed to going back to the other game
yeah I think we did it okay we did what
was needed we achieved our goal thank
you guys so much for hanging out with us
on this wonderful may the fourth be with
you and also with you
sweetie God praise be that yeah so much
for joining us have a great weekend it
is Friday and hi defender I think yeah
it was tie defender but I defender
Oh tie hunter maybe the adding that's
where it is cool cool cool that's gonna
do it thank you guys again for joining
us thank you Mike thank you Peter
bye for hanging out thank you guys again
for hanging out that's gonna do it keep
looking people whooping myself I gotta
watch last Jedi this weekend last Jedi
yeah I guess rather watch like rogue one
but we got a yeah rogue one but we got
um consolo coming up soon I think may
24th yeah may 24th that's the second
holiday yeah
alright that'll do it thank you guys see
ya everyone see ya
[Music]
that was the wrong address
[Music]
[Music]